so you've purchased or about to purchase
elden ring good choice but from software
games are notorious for being obscure
which is part of the charm
so you're wondering hey is there
anything i should know going into elden
ring well lowly tarnished yes
yes indeed there is
at the beginning of from software games
you're typically presented with a
starting gift you can choose between in
eldon ring these choices are crimson
amber medallion lands between rune
golden seed fanged imp ashes cracked pot
stone sword key bewitching branch boiled
prawn and shiburi's woe so which to
choose if you enjoy the idea of being
able to explore hidden areas right away
you might like the stone sword key these
allow you to access various areas in the
game that are locked away by imps that
have good loot and sometimes horrendous
bosses behind them
however while these are somewhat rare
you'll be able to find plenty of them as
you explore the lands between and enough
that you won't need this option there's
the feigned impashes if you want help
right off the bat with spirit ashes
however you can't summon spirit ashes
right away which i'll get to later in
the video so honestly this one doesn't
matter too much the crimson amber
medallion can be tempting as it raises
your hp however there's a far
far better choice the golden seed
this little guy right here is your
answer while you'll find golden seeds
sprinkled throughout the game they are
far more limited and golden seeds are
your ticket to upgrading your flasks of
tears which you use in game to heal and
recover focus points by using a golden
seed you'll be able to add more charges
to your flask which is something you'll
desperately want as you travel deeper
and deeper into dungeons
these charges are your lifeblood and way
to explore or keep fighting a boss as
they can wreck you pretty quickly
and speaking of golden seas these are
definitely something you're going to
want to look for you start out in the
ring with just 4 charges to your flask
of tears that you can distribute between
them golden seeds can typically be found
by exploring the world of the lands
between and finding tiny little earth
trees outside which will always have a
golden seat underneath there are other
ways to find them such as drops from
certain bosses or even npc quest lines
but do yourself a favor and explore the
map for these while you'll probably find
many of them just by naturally
progressing and completing various
dungeons if you are stuck you can always
take a break and go explore unexplored
territories for these oh and golden seas
aren't your only way to upgrade your
flasks of tears you can also find sacred
tiers which upgrade how much each chunk
of your uh
tears do
wow i just realized you're drinking your
own tears in this game anyways secret
tears can be found in various churches
throughout the lands between not every
church has one but many do and these
churches can be found simply by
you guessed it
exploring while character creation at
the beginning of souls games usually
aren't the most important as you can
allot stats as you level up and can
pretty well redo your build as you go if
you aren't happy with how you've chosen
to stat yourself out or your build
fortunately eldon ring has a way to
completely respect your character that's
right later in the game you'll find an
npc i'm not allowed to show that will
allow you to respect your stats you'll
need to give this npc a specific item to
do this an item that's fairly rare
so i don't think you'll have unlimited
respects but you do at least get a few
if you want it
you can even change your character's
appearance at this npc if you decide
you're not happy with how you made them
look and this time is free of charge oh
baby
hit an npc and piss them off don't worry
i mean don't do that but don't worry i
made that mistake
i did it
it it was me in my defense the npc was
trapped and i was trying to see if i
could get them out just uh okay let's
move on before i dig myself a deeper
hole once you piss off an npc they are
permanently aggroed at you
or
are they
as has become standard and from software
games there is a way to unaccurate npcs
who you've accidentally pissed off go
find yourself at the church of vows i'm
not going to spoil where it's located
but once you find this church you'll be
able to atone for your sins as a note
you'll need an item to do this which as
you may have guessed is limited and rare
so we've been talking about how elder
ring is an rpg and you can level up or
redistribute your stats but something
that's kinda important to note is that
you can't level up right away if you're
new to these games exploring the
dungeons and getting frustrated by dying
and losing your runes without being able
to really use them here's how you get
the ability to level up
rest at three sites of grace not one
not two but three three shall be the
number thou shalt count
and the number of the counting shall be
three once you've done that you'll be
given a visit by melina who will grant
you the ability to turn your runes into
strength aka levels
from software games have dabbled with
needing torches to a various degree ever
since dark souls 2.
however eldon ring is the first one
where you will truly consistently want
one there are some dungeons that are
pretty much pitch black without one so
do yourself a favor and buy yourself a
torch the first chance you get which is
likely akali the merchant
and you know what it's only 200 runes
and well worth it
so remember how earlier in the video i
mentioned you can't use spirit ashes
right away to do that you'll need to
find a spirit calling bell and in order
to find it well that's a bit of a
spoiler to be honest so i'm going to
give you some advice doing my best to
avoid spoilers and leave it fairly vague
i hope that helps
every so often try to go back to the
church of ella for a secret surprise
there are various npcs you'll meet
across your time exploring the lands
between several of these are linked in
ways to the region's legacy dungeons for
example you'll find a girl of stormhill
shack who's intricately tied to the boss
of the area godric and even explains her
internal debate about being grafted by
defeating the area's major legacy
dungeon boss godric you'll progress her
storyline one way or another there are
things you can do to alter her storyline
before you defeat godric so you'll
probably want to try and do that first
and she isn't the only npc questline
whose progress is tied to defeating a
major boss
so take it from me as a warning if you
want to see everything these npcs have
to offer
try to see if you can figure out some of
their storylines before defeating those
legacy bosses
of course if you don't care about these
storylines all good but if you do this
is definitely a helpful bit of knowledge
okay you did it you finally defeated
your first legacy dungeon boss and have
obtained their remembrance you can do
one of three things with these
remembrances
one you can use them right away to gain
a huge number of runes
two you can find an npc in the game's
main hub who allows you to turn the
boss's remembrance into one of two
special unique boss items
or three you can hold on to it forever
so you can always read the item
description and be reminded of its lore
that's what i do
that's me
anyways i recommend you be like me do as
i do not for the lore part but because
as it turns out you can find mausoleums
that allow you to duplicate a boss's
remembrance
meaning you can actually get both of
their unique boss items
or get one and spend other on runes or
be like me and just hold on to both of
them forever
i don't know i'm the type of person who
never uses major healing items in rpgs
because i panic that i'm going to run
out
and there you have 9 things i wish i
knew before playing eldon ring alden
ring is absolutely massive and these
tips are just the tip of the iceberg to
get you started and exploring the world
i hope it helps and i hope you enjoyed
stay tuned to gamespot as we have much
more elder ring content on the way
[Music]
[Music]
you